bonsoir a tous très heureuse de vous
retrouver à la une de sa pour garde ce
choix l'impasse de la commission
spéciale sur les retraites les députés
n'ont finalement pas pu venir à bout des
milliers d'amendements de l'opposition
le travail effectué 1 a donc servi à
rien et les compteurs seront remis à
zéro dans l'hémicycle lundi prochain
alors qui est responsable de cet échec
le petit théâtre de cette commission
certaines l'image du parlement et à quoi
sert l'assemblée si les arbitrages se
joue ailleurs notre grand débat est à
suivre sur ce plateau les enfants
influenceurs ils ont dix ans à peine ils
sont déjà des stars du web
il teste des jouets de la nourriture ou
encore des bonbons sur internet ces
jeunes youtuber cumul des millions de
vues sur la toile mais ne sont soumis à
aucun cadre légal
la majorité veut changer cela on en
parlera et puis notre grand témoin ce
soir vient d'être nommé à l'unanimité
jurés de l'académie goncourt il va donc
être le premier couvert de la célèbre
table de chez drouant une place qu'a
occupée en son temps une certaine
colette ou un certain jean giono rien
que ça le philosophe et écrivain pascal
bruckner est avec nous ce soir voilà
vous savez tout sans oublier aussi
nouvelle chronique qui veut prendre sa
place sur la campagne américaine avec
françois durpaire ça y est on y va htc
mais n'oubliez pas c'est parti
[Musique]
et bienvenue à vous chers
téléspectateurs merci d'avoir choisi lcp
nos invités en plateau ce soir pascal
bruckner bonsoir bonsoir merci d'être
notre grand témoin et félicitations pour
commencer pour votre nomination vous
entrez donc dans le cercle très fermé du
des jurés du goncourt
on va en parler on parlera aussi de
votre dernier livre une brève éternité
chez grasset philosophie de la longévité
dans lequel est bien vous explorez les
questions existentielles soulevé par
l'allongement de la vie vous appelez ça
l'été indien de la vie c'est cette
nouvelle période qui s'ouvre allait à
partir de la cinquantaine et qui peut
durer jusqu'à un demi siècle ça vous
intéresse directement parce que il va
falloir justement on est ambitieux un
demi siècle c'est beaucoup en face il ya
50 ans oui c'est rond temple entend y
aller ça peut arriver d'être centenaire
comme 8 bat wil pierre soulages là qui
cassent en temps on a de vous entendre
aussi ce soir sur cette réforme des
retraites puisque c'est l'actualité le
débat en commission spéciale s'est
soldée par un échec bonsoir catherine
fabre bonsoir merci d'être là vous êtes
député la république en marche de
gironde responsable du texte de cette
réforme donc pour la majorité hervé
saulignac bonsoir je député socialiste
de l'ardèche les socialistes qui
réclament une commission denquête sur
l'étude d'impact c'est ce document de
plus de 1000 pages qui a fourni
gouvernement qui est censé prévoir tous
les effets de la réforme et elsa monde
un gars va nous accompagnent ce soir
elle suit cette réforme et ces débats
comme le lait sur le feu pour lcp alors
je vous donne la parole dans un instant
mais celui qui vit nous a préparé une
petite sélection au fond des meilleurs
moments de cette commission spéciale
c'est stéphane son billet tout de suite
si j'ai bien compris
[Musique]
bonsoir et dames bonsoir messieurs
bonsoir pascal bruckner
bonsoir stéphane si j'ai bien compris ce
soir ah bah vous n'avez rien si j'ai
bien compris la commission spéciale des
retraites a travaillé pour rien ou
presque
mais bon je me souviens de ce que disait
philippe meyer qui était assis à votre
place le journalisme semaine dernière y
n'oublions pas que la politique c'est
aussi du théâtre surtout au parlement
alors pour ceux qui auraient raté ses 75
heures de spectacle passionnante du
débat dans les commissions spéciales des
retraites je vous propose un best-of
donc ça ne ferait sans doute pas un
carton d'audience sur tf1
ça tombe bien sur lcp bon histoire de
rendre les choses un peu plus
palpitantes j'ai quand même demandé à
pascal de participer un petit peu à
cette chronique donc à la rentrée au
jury goncourt parce qu'elle vous allez
devoir élire les meilleurs livres là je
vous propose d'élire les meilleures
interventions de l'opposition
donc j'ai choisi l ère socialiste ayant
soumis on y va sur les républicains pour
commencer qui est nominé alors là la
prime à l'expérience gilles carez de 71
ans est une pointure en matière de
budget à porter des finances pendant
longtemps mais là il a joué une autre
carte sa carte d'élu local puisqu'il est
élu de champigny sur marne dans l'
écoute ce que je voudrais proposer c'est
au rapporteur dans les semaines qui
viennent de venir passer deux heures
place lénine un vendredi matin à
champigny et qu'on parle ensemble avec
nos concitoyens de la valeur
d'acquisition de la valeur de service de
la chd équilibre du coefficient
d'ajustement
parce que je pense qu'il faudra qu'on
soit deux crs comprend pourquoi vous
l'avez choisi les républicains donc
c'est lui
les socialistes qui avaient vous nommez
allait se salissent moi j'ai un faible
pour valérie rabault merkel quand c'est
très très clair quand elle part dès
qu'elle sort sa calculette
elle trouve une faille dans l'étude
d'impact du gouvernement mais il y en a
qui connaît très très bien le dossier au
sud avec en plus le sens de la formule
boris vallot là votre réforme
elle porte sur des dizaines et des
dizaines photo n'est pas partir des
centaines de points furent s'il
s'agissait que d'une réforme de
pénibilité mais c'est la pénibilité les
carrières longues
vous engager tous les françaises et les
français sur 60 ans qui a des effets de
bord dans tous les sens des transferts
ça va changer niveau des pensions le
niveau le niveau d'aidé des cotisations
et voir des caisses qui vont demeurer
des caisses qui vont pas demeurer
pendant des décennies vous allez avoir
un doublon entre
entre tous des gens qui rentrent dans
les carrières même moment ont pas le
niveau de pension va ça va être dur on
est en train de s'engager dans un truc
qui va ressemble un peu aux briques site
quoi dire qu'une fois que vous l'aurez
voter vous surtout comment faire pour
vous en sortir a là rien que ça bouge
pas mal est fait breakbeats effet
réforme des retraites du côté des
insoumis j'imagine que vous avez retenu
jean luc mélenchon alors non je
reconnais mélenchon c'est toujours un
plaisir
il parle comme un livre même quand on
n'est pas d'accord avec lui c'est très
très agréable de l'entendre s'exprimer
mais le plus offensif c'était quand même
adrien theaux tenace qui a donc que je
pense réussi à faire énervé à peu près
l'opposition une fois par par par heure
et là c'est le moment où il a suscité un
cri d'indignation générale pardon dans
les rangs de la majorité on écoute en
réalité le maquereau nisme nous fait
regretter l'honnêteté de la droite
républicaine
parce que là mais oui mais je vais vous
le dire on m'attendait parce que la
droite républicaine elle l est pour une
mesure d'âge et elle le dit elle
considère que la solution c'est
effectivement de reculer l'âge de départ
à la retraite c'est un point de
désaccord fondamental entre nous tout le
monde l'aura compris mais au moins elle
dit la vérité aux français sur ce
qu'elles souhaitent et sur le paramètre
sur lequel elle souhaite jouer un c'est
l'heure du verdict
il faut choisir maintenant pascal calais
était la meilleure intervention selon
vous côté opposition carrese 4 mince on
va l'eau va louer le plus clair et 4 na
c'est le plus vrai je pense mais ça
prouve bien que tout le monde est perdu
dans cette lacune une réforme classique
aurait repoussé d'un an ou de l'âge de
départ à la retraite lui qu'il dise
mieux selon vous des trois c'est c'est
boris vallot bourhis vallot donc voila a
été dominé lui pardon les récompenses du
côté de la majorité
ça va assez vite un jeu avec ces
personnes il ya quand même un député de
la majorité qui est largement au dessus
du ruisseau livier verront donc quand il
parle ça te souvent mouche et là c'est
un ancien socialiste qui parle à ceux
qui sont restés socialiste en écoute je
vous dis une chose les profs ils ont été
revalorisées à la fin des années 80 au
début des années 90 a été dit par
guillaume boucher chat ou de tout à
l'heure depuis plus rien le niveau
quasiment plus rien c'était sous la
gauche que ça a été fait je vous dire un
truc moi en cinq ans de mandat
socialiste j'aurais bien aimé qu'on
revalorise les profs j'aurais adoré voté
un amendement qui disait qu'on allait
revaloriser les profs j'aurais sauté de
joie si on m'avait fait voter un
amendement disant
injectés dès l'année prochaine 500
millions d'euros de rémunération de plus
pour les enseignants et qu'on allait
mettre 10 milliards d'euros de plus sur
la carrière des enseignants ils vont
avoir une meilleure rémunération pendant
leur activité et un même niveau de
pension de retraite ça vous embête ça
nous fait plaisir à la règlement de
comptes entre anciens socialement mais
les socialistes
effectivement alors c'est l'heure tant
attendue le suspense et dans son
comblement lcvr d'or de la meilleure
prestation de cette commission spéciale
alors il est la clr d'or donc je vous
fais passer attention tout suspense
évidemment pendant que sa tournée vous
promettez l'enfournement tambou ballon
enfin savoir été pourvus cette enveloppe
chère commencée 75 heures de spectacle
des cvr ça vous regarde notre émission
allez-y croyez mais participe au
spectacle de l'accommodation
[Musique]
brigitte bourguignon savez qui c'est
bête on sait pas qui c'est la présidente
de la commission spéciale des railleries
quelque chose m'a échappé je vous ai
tendu un piège parce qu'ils étaient donc
on la connaît peut donc c'est une
députée en marge du pas de calais une
ancienne socialisme elle a une mission
quasiment impossible ont quitté mener
cette commission de débat où les
insoumis était vraiment pour le coin se
mit donc il ya eu plusieurs fois des
interruptions de parole elle a réduit
leur temps de parole alors pas toujours
été comme ça on la regarde vous marrer
mais quand même c'est qu'on n'a pas du
tout ça suffit maintenant vous nous
prenez pour des imbéciles et on vous
parlait une sonné pour des imbéciles en
plus vous messieurs ne sera pas écouté
écoutez moi alors monsieur alors
le alley-oop moi j'aime bien cette
manière justement de congés cycle
débordement de temps de parole barinas
quoi tu n'as donc les insoumis pour être
mécontents et d'ailleurs ils ont été ont
protesté mais je crois que le plus bel
hommage qui a été rendu finalement à
brigitte bourguignon c'est de la part de
jean luc mélenchon lui même donc bravo
madame la présidente c'est mélenchon qui
dit je suis un vieux parlementaire que
vous savez j'ai assisté à d'autres
batailles d'obstruction j'aime mieux
vous dire que ça n'avait pas le niveau
que j'ai trouvé dans cette commission
ce n'est donc pas vraiment ce qu'on peut
appeler de l'obstruction ça a été un
débat et la présidente de séance a
permis que d'un amendement à l'autre on
puisse compléter notre
union merci on aura fait notre maximum
pour d'avoir votre regard ya évidemment
un petit théâtre qui s'est installée
dans cette commission comment vous
regardez le citoyen que vous êtes tous
ces échanges est ce que vous y comprenez
quelque chose alors présomption moment
j'ai compris au début
encore la semaine dernière j'ai lu cinq
pages complètes du monde sur la réforme
des retraites avec des pour et des
comptes
là je décroche un petit peu parce que je
vois la sueur je m'intéresse à d'autres
choses mais ça ça trop duré cette
réforme des retraites a commencé en
septembre
on est en février je pense qu'on joue on
en parlera encore il y aura des grèves
pendant france donc il faut quelques
grèves chaque mois pour épicer un peu le
le climat mais là je ne comprends pas et
entend voilà je vois catherine membres
passe quelque chose de très simple et
que chaque citoyen avec son cerveau
obtus puissent appréhender sans se noyer
dans les débats les contre-feux des
propositions enfin tout s'achète et sec
de la commission spéciale beaucoup
d'amendements on s'y attendait mais
c'est aussi l'échec devant les citoyens
qui ont regardé notamment sur le compte
twitter des cpc ces échanges à vous
rendre lisible c'est quand même
tristement voir déjà je relativiser
l'échec de la commission moi je pense
que on a quand même pu travailler on a
quand même eu beaucoup d'heures de
débats qui ont permis et je trouve que
les extraits que vous avez montré montre
aussi qu'on a pu faire traire le faire
un message sur le fond alors je
reprendrai olivier ferrand qui
effectivement est assez bon mais qui
remontre effectivement que ce qu'on
propose aux enseignants c'était quelque
chose qui pouvait être vue comme une
opportunité donc on a quand même c'est
de faire passer des messages et des uns
et des autres et ensuite sur le fond sur
le fait que les français comprennent ou
pas la réforme
je pense qu'il faut revenir aux
fondamentaux les fondamentaux que qu'on
expose depuis des mois et des mois
maintenant puisque en fait ça fait ça
fait deux ans quelque part que cette
réforme est en préparation
alors pourquoi est-ce que c'est
compliqué je pense que la retraite d'un
côté c'est anxiogène et de notre côté
quand on a beaucoup d'ambition avec
cette réforme on veut on veut vraiment
réparer les défauts du système actuel et
donc on a pris le temps on a fait des
consultations citoyennes en a énormément
concertée au début et jusqu'au moment où
finalement on a présenté le système
cible jusqu'au moment où jean paul
delevoye a présenté le rapport je crois
que c'était assez clair et assez bien
tu parlais janssen cible c'est-à-dire la
réforme ce qu'on veut mettre en place et
cosy l'universel contre l'autre en place
ce qui met peut-être un peu de
difficulté à comprendre c'est le moment
de la transition c'est ce qu'on confie
quelque part à chacune des professions
pour voir comment est-ce qu'on va
pendant 15 ans ou 20 ans arrivé vers là
où je souhaitais position c'est qu'il
manque aussi des éléments il manque
restons typiquement et sur le but
journal passe quand même parce qu'on va
faire sur le fond mais on a avancé on a
fait valoir certains amendements qu'on a
accepté du ps de jean pierre c'est une
forme d'échec quand même causé on verra
qu'une commission spéciale n'arrive pas
au bon bien c'est une première c'est une
première à ma condition savez moi j'ai
habité je fais l'opposition avec ses
milliers d'amendements j'hésite usagers
j'hésite entre l'échec ou le naufrage il
ya quelque chose qui tourne plus rond
dans nos institutions
il ya quelque chose qui ne va pas parce
que il ya soit disant une concertation
qui dure un an un an et demi
et puis un texte de 300 pages
accompagnées d'une étude d'impact de
plus de 1000 pages des boules quatre
jours avant l'assemblée nationale c'est
une provocation et à cette provocation
d'un françaises soumises il répond par
une autre provocation à la drogue le
règlement lui permet 19 mai et on se
retrouve dans une situation parlement
qui est maltraité d'abord et ensuite
l'opposition qui se défend c'est ça
l'idée mais bien sûr que c'est le
parlement qui m'a traité parce que
qu'est-ce qui s'est passé c'est que les
groupes d'opposition qui ont souhaité
faire un travail le plus sérieux du
monde en déposant des amendements limité
pour avoir des questions précises à des
questions précises ils n'ont pas pu
avoir leurs débats moi j'ai assisté à
une partie de ping pong entre la
majorité les députés en marche et la
france insoumise ça m'intéresse pas et
les français ça ne les intéresse pas
donc je considère que font les infos
1000 les plus audibles sur la
contestation extrêmement précise que
nous avions posé comment on calcule le
point quelles vont être les conséquences
pour les femmes s'étaient fait des tas
de questions
et au final n'y a pas de réponse donc
c'est quand même un naufrage elsa
impasse ce soir qu'est ce qui va se
passer maintenant on prend les mêmes et
on recommence ça ça dès lundi exactement
et on peut continuer à filer la
métaphore le spectacle est à peu près le
même
le gouvernement va présenter tout
d'abord le
même texte qui est entré en commission
travail de la commission ça n'aura servi
finalement que de répétition générale
pour les acteurs les acteurs ce seront
les mêmes les personnages principaux la
majorité avec les rapporteurs le
ministre et puis la france insoumise des
personnages secondaires les autres
groupes qui essayent aussi d'exister
dans le débat puis au niveau de
l'histoire et bien c'est la même pour ou
contre cette réforme des retraites
on aura les mêmes arguments de chaque
côté obstruction scandera la majorité
texte à trous répondre à l'opposition
et bien voilà on va retrouver exactement
les mêmes arguments en séance publique
avec toujours cette impression pour
l'opposition et bien qu'il ya des scènes
un petit peu que la vérité se joue
ailleurs
la concertation entre le premier
ministre et les syndicats on attend des
annonces sur la pénibilité demain par
exemple ou encore la conférence de
financement ça les oppositions non
souligné à de très nombreuses reprises
je pense qu'eric woerth a dû poser
trente fois la question on les écoute
c'est un peu comme dans un repas de
famille d'une certaine manière quand on
a des grandes familles il ya la table
des enfants et puis à la table des
parents alors à la table des parents on
parle des choses importantes
et puis à la table des enfants on
s'amuse j'ai l'impression que à la table
des parents ayez le gouvernement et les
syndicats qui négocient sur le
financement du texte et puis à la table
des enfants un peu nous catherine fabre
oui vous êtes à la table des enfants
mais c'est vrai que quand l'essentiel le
financement la question de l'âge
d'équilibrer la question de la
pénibilité se décident ailleurs c'est à
quoi sert le parlement mais c'est pas
l'essentiel l'essentiel non l'essentiel
c'est le cap
on est en train de fixer le cadre le le
système universel que l'on veut pour
demain les députés
c'est ça leur mission c'est de fixer le
cap c'est quand même ça l'essentiel
et bien qu'elle soit doit le savoir à
quel âge ils devront partir à taux plein
c'est important ce cet âge là pour eux
est ce que ces 65 est ce que c'est cette
façon ça c'est dans l'étude d'impact est
effectivement le fait que ensuite ce
soit la gouvernance qui est à le fixer
au fil du temps on le sait depuis le
début et c'est très bien que les
partenaires sociaux sauf que
là dedans mais une solution alternative
à cet âge de 64 ans qui permettrait de
financer la réforme et à ce moment là et
pas dans l'étude d'impact c'est dans la
concurrence devenue en semant défense ce
qu'on sait c'est que la réforme va
démarrer à l' équilibre et ensuite qu'on
laisse ces les moyens d'arriver à
l'équilibré partenaires sociaux certes
mais ça c'est très bien c'est leur
responsabilité moi ça me convient très
bien on s'assure qu'il y ait un
équilibre on s'assure qu'ils aient de
grandes règles cadre les règles d'or
qu'on a voté d'ailleurs parce qu'on a
été au bout d'un texte en commission
vous dites que la commission a été un
échec en a quand même été au bout du
projet de loi ils sont les avancées qu
est ce que vous avez décidé un peu plus
important qui fixé la règle d'or n'est
fixé la valeur six articles sur 70
autres acides dans la loi ordinaire
c'est-à-dire tiana 38 qu'on n'a même pas
abordée c'est quand même incroyable mais
qui sont au fur et à mesure qu'on
discutait d'un certain nombre d'articles
on apprenait que des décisions ont été
prises à l'extérieur par exemple plus
belles séquences c'est lorsque une
dépêche afp nous informe que madame b to
b a trouvé un accord avec les avocats
alors nous on est en train de discuter
de ce sujet entre députés mais on
apprend et on apprend que face à
l'extérieur le sujet aurait été avec les
liens qu'elle taser abbey s'est avéré
que ce n'était pas le cas c'est beaucoup
et novateur le député dans une réforme
aussi importante c'est une blague on
sent que la retraite je vais te dire
qu'il ya des discussions qui sont
ouvertes avec les syndicats
que ce soit les grandes centrales
laurent berger l'unsa avec les avocats
il ya des annonces de main du premier
ministre la pénibilité et en même temps
c'est lui qui vote la loi le législateur
mais on a l'impression qu'il est un peu
court circuiter oui il a été un peu
escamoté mais la vraie question en fait
et on voit bien que même les députés ont
du mal à se repérer dans cet énorme
dossier
c était illégitime de lancer cette
réforme des retraites maintenant
et dire que ça intervient après la crise
des gilet jaune qui a quand même mis la
france à genoux là on vient d'avoir deux
mois de grève et on se dit est ce que le
président pourrait peut être réfrénés
pendant quelques années son appétit de
retraite sont limpides yves revol de
retraite est est ce que le pays pourrait
voilà avancer normalement sans qu'on
samcon même temps c'est fait dans son
programme oui d'accord vous à young et
il ya un moment il faut aussi savoir
rêver se réfréner danse à ce tourbillon
de réforme c'est après le mouvement des
idées jaune les retraites moi je pense
que c'était dans son programme je pense
que les français attendent une réforme
c'est toujours très difficile de
réformes en france c'est vrai mais je
pense que les français nous attendent
sur cette réforme
d'autant que vous dites suite au gilet
jaune mais c'est une réforme qui va
justement protéger les plus vulnérables
c'est une réforme qui va augmenter la
retraite de près de 30% de 25 % de
français les plus vulnérables donc c'est
vraiment une réforme qu'on doit fermer
pendant annoncé la responsable et c'est
un peu plus de temps c'était pas un
visage parce que puisque ça fait deux
ans qu'on la prépare non mais là on
parle du rôle du parlement pour lcp on
trouve que on se demande si les députés
finalement on n'aura pas mérité d'avoir
un peu plus de temps qu'est ce qui
l'empêché la date des municipales le
calendrier dalle emmanuel macron les
députés ça fait deux ans qu'on préparait
la langue en commission par le travail
de la collection mais vous mais vous
également être pas tout seul à
l'assemblée langage comme savez mes
mémoires des toiles à montpellier le
voir y ait pu rentrer depuis juillet
vous savez exactement le système cible
comporte et ensuite les questions de
transition ce sont des questions que
depuis le début on dit qu'on souhaite
donner aux mains justement des personnes
concernées donc moi je n'ai pas de
problème avec vous et je vous les
éléments de davos un autre exemple de la
presse est vide et a suggéré hier le
conseil d'état on parle à votre place et
veut alexis corbière il ya quelques
jours qui disait je viens d'arriver avec
cette étude d'impact
voulez-vous qu'on arrive à ingurgiter ça
en si peu de temps
ça c'est un argument qui vaut pour tous
les députés quels que soient les partis
politiques alors écoutez moi je lui
l'étude d'impact et on avait réussi à
davie bien sûr c'est non mais
sérieusement
non mais sérieusement la vie bien sûr
que la vidéo en battant h harry n'est
qu'une fine et vous ne lisez pas
sérieusement 1029 pages qui suppose par
ailleurs qu'on se fasse accompagner par
des experts pour nous éclairer sur des
roulettes amenés à nous arriver qui se
donne pas elle est quand même assez
facile à écrire alors justement
incertain
on la parcourt très vite c'est régler
quelques points est vraiment pas tout
parce qu'on n'a pas fait pour ce soir
sur quoi cette commission spéciale a
avancé est ce qu'il ya eu quand même un
certain nombre d'inquiétudes lever ou le
doute persiste il ya deux ans je pour la
majorité en séance publique où vous
allez vraiment devoir rassurer dans la
commission spéciale on a vu des
questions sur la valeur du point
le premier ministre avait dit il sera il
évoluera en fonction des salaires
et puis c'est devenu en fonction du
revenu moyen par tête finalement revenu
d'activité parts est un indicateur qui
n'existe pas encore ça on a vu un le
ministre a dit ce sera plus favorable
on va l'écouter mais on va on a bien vu
que ça a soulevé énormément de doutes
dans la commission donc on aura un
indicateur aggloméré qui sera précisée
est donné en décret au conseil d'état et
c'est bien l'insee organisme indépendant
qui le produira tous les ans il ya
vraiment rien d'autre que ça je pense
qu'il faut éteindre la polémique avant
c'est un petit peu sur autre chose
il a du mal à les peindre cette
polémique est ce que ça donne le
sentiment d'un décalage entre ce qui a
été dit au début et ce qui se retrouve
dans le projet de loi
et puis aussi à la question de l'âge qui
reste quand même très floue puisque dans
le texte
bah il n'y a pas vraiment d'âge
d'équilibré on parle d'un âge déquilibre
sans vraiment le définir sa serre portal
à la conférence de financement mais on
voit dans l'étude d'impact souvent ses
65 ans bref sur l'âge sur le point sur
le coup garantir que le dollar est pas
hélas d'équilibré sur ça que vous allez
être vraiment attendez on se rend compte
quand même que des doutes sont encore là
donc garantir que le point ne baissera
pas sans on avait bien senti c'est une
inquiétude des français et c'est
exactement la fait voter aujourd'hui
dans le projet de loi organique
l'assurance justement que la valeur du
point ne baisseraient pas et suivrez
l'inflation donc ça c'est la première
chose sur l'indicateur on n'est pas que
sur des salariés puisqu'il ya les
indépendants il ya les agriculteurs il a
les professions libérales donc il
fallait un indicateur qui ne parle pas
que des salaires c'est pour ça qu'il ya
cet indicateur l'indicateur sur lequel
le point est indexé pour être sûr qu'il
ne baissera pas ça pour être sur hiller
ne m'en avait dit le niveau des salaires
rajouter le capital les autres choses
qui vous protégera gouvieux jours qu'il
augmente aussi vite que les revenus
moyens partait donc la france est tout à
fait logique - ne baissera pas même dans
50 ans il restera le point ne baissera
pas et la cua suivra l'inflation il
augmentera mais pourra pas baisser 1,0
l'âge parce que là aussi c'est étonnant
hervé saulignac et puis je vous donne la
parole juste après pascal bodmer
moi j'avais compris que on était sur un
hd kiliba 64 ans c'était fameuse âges
pivots qui était avancée par le premier
ministre l'étude d'impact parle de 65
ans les français qui regardent se disent
bas alors finalement être hype longtemps
mais même encore peut-être même plus
longtemps expliqué nous ça j'ai pas
censé vous l'expliquer mais le principe
de l'âge pivot c'est que au fur et à
mesure que l'espérance de vie progresse
cet âge pivot lui aussi avancent donc ça
fait partie des inconnus enfin permettez
moi juste un mot quand même vous aviez
parlé tout à l'heure de de l'indexation
du point excusez moi de vous dire que
c'est le coeur du réacteur vous avez
prévu une réforme énorme colossal une ré
centrales nucléaires vous avez juste
oublié d'étudier le coeur du réacteur et
vous nous demandez de nous prononcer
pour engager la vie de millions de
français sans que l'on sache ce que sera
cette indexation c'est absolument
impensable
incroyable et même je crois que
constitutionnellement vous allez avoir
de vrais soucis là dessus parce que je
ne vois pas comment moins je peux en
conscience me prononcer alors que vous
avez avoué que cet indicateur n'existe
pas que l'insee aller le créer ce même
insee dit je n'ai jamais été saisi et je
ne suis pas au courant de cette demande
là enfin on nage en plein délire
et c'est extrêmement préoccupant moi je
pense qu'il faut rassurer les français
parce qu'ils sont ils sont mais donnez
nous l'occasion ni rassurée parce que
quand même qu'on en vienne à votre lit
parce que c'est intéressant vous vous
avez déjà une petite idée de ce qu'il
faudrait faire d'une certaine manière
mais alors vous répondez est sur le
point et sur l'âge et oui on avance sur
le point sur l'âge sur les deux mois ce
que je peux dire c'est que la volonté
c'est que justement au moment où se
fassent la transition
on va on va garder exactement la même
ambition sur les retraites on va garder
exactement la même enveloppe financière
donc la valeur du point inquiétant il va
y avoir plus de retraités au moment de
la transition je parle du moment de là
ambition est justement la manière
ensuite dont ça va évoluer voulurent a
d'une manière plus favorable que ce qui
existe aujourd'hui puisque aujourd'hui
les points sont indexées sur l'inflation
et demain ils le seront sur les revenus
ou sur les salaires mais en tout cas ça
sera supérieure à l'inflation et ça vous
le savez bien
donc moi je rassure en disant l'ambition
elle est exactement l'avait donc
aujourd'hui et l'évolution elle sera
supérieure à l'évolution d'aujourd'hui
or l'agent revanche il faudra attendre
parce qu'on ne sait pas ce qu baby sur
l'argent ce qu'on assume très bien c'est
de dire que effectivement plus
l'espérance de vie augmente plus il
faudra que les français travaillent et
ça ça me paraît assez logique et c'est
la responsabilité qu'on doit à nos
enfants et aux générations futures
ensuite nous se comporte à la différence
des républicains qui veulent une mesure
d'âge rigide
nous ce qu'on porte c'est de laisser le
choix aux français de pouvoir partir un
peu plus tôt ou un peu plus tard selon
leurs préférences et c'est bien ça tout
l'intérêt du système à points il est là
et forcément si on part un peu plus tôt
ben pour l'équilibré au moins d'argent
longtemps on a un beau ni la philosophie
mais on est vraiment un principe de
liberté c'est intéressant parce que au
fond votre réflexion sur la question de
l'âge au fond comment on vit à partir de
55 65 est maintenant de plus en plus
longtemps et rentre complètement
résonance avait avec ce débat parce que
dans votre livre vous expliquez pour
vous la retraite c'est le cauchemar ces
sinistres en fait cette ya un impensé en
fait d'après on est en train de parler
de l'âge que vous voudriez au fond vous
le plus tard possible
s'il fallait le départ s'il fallait
choisir ça dépend pour qui
je pense qu'effectivement la liberté
c'est de partir quand on veut et de ne
pas partir si on n'a pas envie de partir
c'est l'âge de la retraite au japon en
allemagne c'est 67 en belgique ses 76
ans 10 ans pour un prof risques pour soi
disant pour un bûcheron cpe - là donc il
faut moduler selon les professions mais
on devrait laisser la liberté aux gens
de partir aux états unis vous savez que
vous pouvez travailler aussi tard que
possible ce qu'on voit des caissières
qui ont 80 ans et des profs pendant 90
et c'est souvent d'ailleurs leurs élèves
meurent avant eux quand ils sont en
bonne santé ses professeurs vous parlez
aussi de la retraite comme au fond une
forme de mise au rebut
oui sauf pour les métiers manuels
difficile où les métiers
psychologiquement épuisant énormément
d'hommes et de femmes vivent leur départ
à la retraite comme une défaite
militaire puisque retraites c'est un
mode à d'une armée battue est passé les
premiers jours les premiers mois
d'euphorie
ils se sentent inutiles et au fond le
grand défi de l'allongement de la durée
de la vie c'est pas simplement
d'accorder à chacun une bonne retraite
c'est de donner un sens à 25 ou 30 ans
d'existence supplémentaires et de ne pas
mettre tous ces gens en vacances
obligatoires
et que font la plupart des gens bailly
déprimé tombalbaye une crise d'identité
donc le défi c'est pas simplement de
faire une réforme des retraites c'est de
faire une réforme du de l'été indien de
la vie c'est à dire ses 25 ans
supplémentaire qu'est ce qu'on va faire
et ces gens lorsqu'ils sont en bonne
santé physique et mentale
on sera en pleine possession de leurs
moyens sont des gens qui ont des
compétences des expériences et qui n'ont
qu'une envie c'est que l'âge moyen d'un
bonne santé je crois que c'est à 104 on
ne sait pas non plus élevé que ça on
plus récemment des indicateurs très
fiable on sait pas trop ce que d'avoir
des déclarations le fait d'avoir été
opéré à 60 ans d'avoir des petits bobos
ne vous empêche pas d'être valide et
donc on parlait aussi d'un autre risque
dont on parle peu c'est une forme
d'hostilité entre les générations le
risque de dresser des les jeunes contre
les vieux qu'on peut le résoudre
d'une certaine façon en travaillant plus
longtemps oui parce qu'il ya une enquête
qui a été fait je crois par les échos
sur les super centenaires donc au milieu
du siècle il y aura à peu près 200
milles centenaires en france il y aura
moins plus de centenaires que de que
d'actifs ce qui va poser des problèmes
monstrueux et donc imaginer dans la même
famille aura cinq générations les
centenaires des septuagénaires les
quinquagénaires les quadragénaires et
les légendes 20 ans et donc comment on
va financer la santé tous ces gens là
parce qu'à centenaire ça coûte cher
c'est très beau quand ça tiers mais sa
couche et un septuagénaire ça commence
aussi à faire des frais
et qui va hériter de l'argent du
centenaire pas le septuagénaire parce
qu'il a déjà fait sa vie et peut-être
que le sens terre va dire je donne mes
biens ou mama fortune à mes arrières
petits enfants qui font des études et
qui en ont besoin
donc on est l'allongement de la durée la
vie est un cadeau merveilleux de la
science mais qui est aussi un cadeau
empoisonné et auquel on doit penser tout
de suite parce qu'on n'a pas les
réponses pour l'instant on espérait
magiquement que les retraités à l'aide
de la beauté très vite après la retraite
et donc on aurait moins de frais pour la
nation mais pas du tout pas du tout ils
tiennent ils s'accrochent sur vous
parlez de l'interdire mais il ya un
moment où justement conseiller secousses
les fins de vie peuvent être contraints
très pénible très difficile et
l'allongement de la durée de la vie
avant ça elle accompagnait ces reculs
ils vont parler sans terre donc quand on
parle de 100 g soit votre audition par
les brèves éternité philosophie de la
longévité chez chez grasset peut-être
vous saisissez vous de ce débat au fond
sur voilà sept
cette phase de la vie où on veut
continuer à être arrivé plus un déclin
et qui n'est plus un déclin pendant que
tout le monde voit la vraie différence
c'est qu'en forme le défi de la société
pour les deux syndicats
exactement merci beaucoup d'être venu
sur le plateau de lcp
elsa vous continuez à suivre ça on se
retrouve lundi c'est l'heure
d'accueillir françois durpaire pour une
nouvelle rubrique avant cela on va
écouter est certain qu'une bouteille
djedj vous souvenez c'était la surprise
de la primaire dans l'iowa
cette fois il s'est incliné face à
bernie sanders dans le new hampshire
écoutez le féliciter son aîné avant
d'accueillir françois j'admirais le
sénateur sanders quand j'étais au lycée
je le respecte encore beaucoup
aujourd'hui et je le félicite pour ses
bons résultats ce soir vous avez été si
nombreux à voter des démocrates pur et
dur des indépendants qu'ils veulent pas
rester sur la touche et même quelques
nouveaux ex républiques un prêt à voter
pour quelque chose de nouveau
et cette chronique
elle s'appelle qui veut prendre sa place
et elle est signée françois durpaire
c'est parti très heureuse de vous
retrouver françois toutes les semaines
mais vous viendrez nous dire qui veut
prendre la place de donald trump alors
deuxième étape de la primaire démocrate
bernie sanders soulagé et même bernie
sanders galvanisé non oui galvanisé
normalement le nude shy c'est l'état de
la clarification on y voit plus clair
après new york alors oui on y voit plus
qu'à on va voir des images c'est bernie
sanders
il est très content de sa victoire
organise qui va dire et permettez moi de
dire ce soir que cette victoire est le
début de la fin pour donald trump sa
place le début de la fin début de la fin
bon et ben ça va pas être facile quand
même avec presque 50 % de popularité
pour trump et sanders il veut pas
l'élection lui veut la révolution il
veut renverser la table et c'est pas
trop elle est à gagner de noam schalit
mais il n'a pas vraiment ce qu'il veut
notamment les jeunes qui se sont pas
très mobilisés sont moins mobilisés qui
a 4 ans contre sanders et le problème
c'est que on à sanders qui s'affirme
l'avant mais face à lui on sait pas on
n'a pas encore le duel va regarder un
peu les duels possibles
le premier duel possible c'est sanders
contre eux et vous allez le voir tout de
suite c'est beauty djedj battant vous
connaissez son nom était là et vous
compte voilà vous connaissez son nom et
à laisser sans visage alors il a des
capacités beauty djedj il incarne un
changement générationnel 38 ans
ouvertement gai c'est important il l'a
dit autrement le dirais pas time avec
ses compagnons son mari voilà on va dire
le premier homme à la maison blanche
avec son mari et et surtout depuis
kennedy les changements générationnels
sa chance avant on parle beaucoup de
génération c'est important deuxième duel
possible mes beauty jamila pas la voix
des minorités donc c'est pas encore sûr
deuxième c'est bye donne vous allez le
reconnaître et hebeisen est alors il a
fait très mal dans le new hampshire il
est très très loin
il a perdu dans l'iowa mais on peut pas
complètement le sortir de la course
pourquoi mais parce que lui il voit la
voix des minorités et bientôt il y aura
la caroline du sud
il peut revenir dans la cour est donc
lui il n'est pas du tout à ce jeu là
qu'on peut l'accord élimine et surtout
qu'il a était favori pendant tellement
deux semaines on peut pas le mettre de
côté
comme ça je fais troisième duel possible
alors là vous peut-être que tout le
monde ne va pas la connaître
il s'agit de amy klobuchar s'est
découvert femmes mais oui c'est la seule
femme qui peut l'emporter parce que
warren la helaba est dans les choux bon
donc avant qu'ils voulaient warren a mis
l arrière sénatrice sénatrice du
minnesota elle a fait un débat télé le
week-end dernier excellent lé troisième
d'une urne shy sort un peu de nulle part
sénatrice du minnesota la presse
américaine se demande est ce que c'est
un feu de paille ou est ce qu'elle va
s'installer et ce cas va être
l'alternative et d'américains qui arrive
à faire surgir comme ça des cordes et
des candidates et on se dit peut-être la
première femme présidente pourquoi pas
et enfin le dernier duel possible à y
caser mail anders contre bloomberg et
bloomberg l'homme qui valait 50
milliards de dollars lui investi
beaucoup lui viendra que au moment du
super tuesday
c'est à dire le 3 mars prochain mais ça
peut être aussi parce qu'il n'était pas
parti la démocratie américaine mais pour
le coup ça marche plutôt sa stratégie
parce que c'est tellement le bazar chez
les démocrates qui peut arriver comme un
sauveur au moment du super tuesday et
puis il ya un duel ça c'est le deuil des
démocrates
voyez on n'a pas très clairement un duel
qui se dégage comme le duel entre
saunders et clinton entre obama et
clinton
on n'a pas ce duel air et on en a un
duel qu'on connaît déjà et qui fait pas
un pli regardez c'est d'un côté donald
trump et de l'autre côté bill wells
alors ville où elle la personne ne
connaît évidemment c'est l'adversaire de
donald trump vient dé frime
air republic son camp la république
alors c'est quelqu'un qui déteste donald
trump a il a dit moi j'aurais voté pour
sa destitution même si je suis
républicain donald trump est un raciste
enragé dès que je suis élu président je
reviens dans l'accord de paris à la fin
des débats
et puis non non passante de primaire non
parce que dans l'iowa g vous donner de
chiffres 91% pour donald trump dans le
new hampshire 85% pour donald trump donc
ça veut dire que la réalité c'est que
donald a dit il a perdu d'avancé bill
oued et vous n'êtes pas obligés
d'apprendre son nom et donald trump
pendant que les autres font une vraie
campagne primaire lui il fait une vraie
campagne générale il prend un temps
d'avancé
c'est à dire en gros il est comme ceux
finalistes qui attend l'autre demi
finalistes qui est en train de faire des
prolongations et qu en train de
s'épuiser dépensé toute son énergie dans
une campagne plus la campagne dure du
côté démocrate est plus donald trump est
sûre d'être réélue elle est écrite
d'avancé sénatrice du texas dont vous
parlez qui peut être va émerger
puis peut-être peep-toe buts et deux
juges dont le nom est pas facile à
prononcer a aussi peut-être une chance
mais bernie sanders il est assez âgée là
pour le coup et puis il a eu un
infarctus donc c'est pas bon et
éviterait 78 eur on a beau aimer les
personnes âgées
j'ai quatre ans parce que regarder avc
il revient bedu c'est incroyable du feu
de dieu il est là et il anime la
jeunesse c'est les jeunes américains
démocrates c'est lui le changement
et puis c'est pas du socialisme la façon
mcgovern 1972 vraiment un vieux
socialisme marxiste léniniste c'est un
socialiste écolo qui propose quelque
chose avec lui et par lui
donc c'est ça son problème est alors joe
biden fait des gaffes donc il a payé il
n'a pas beaucoup de chance d'être sûr et
ça de près oui je suis de près oui c'est
passionnant mais bon train pas davantage
énorme et puis de le fait qu'il était
acquitté le renfort et puis là il a
l'arrogance du vainqueur déjà la suite
du programme
alors la suite du programme pas ce
samedi le samedi d'après le 22 février
on va aller voter dans le nevada donc
nevada on commence à avoir une
sociologique est plus proche de
l'électorat démocrate c'est à dire que
les minorités sont importantes dans les
hispaniques dans le nevada et ensuite on
va en caroline du sud le samedi d'après
le 29 février avec un électorat afro
américains la sib hayden père dans
caroline du sud je vous annoncerai sera
la fin de binationaux on suit le fameux
super tuesday vous revenez ce serait
vraiment envie et bien de découvrir
épisode par épisode chaque semaine ces
brimades flic sens et passionnant parce
qu'elle voulait on va parler un tout
petit peu de vous je vais vous montrer
ces images vous restez avec nous
françois regarder leur père de
l'académie goncourt
c'est cet endroit là que vous allez
fréquenté beaucoup plus que d'habitude
là on voit l'image
didier decoin donc qui succède à bernard
pivot à la tête du jury des goncourt la
célèbre table où vous allez participer à
toutes les délibérations forêt de
caméras il ya des codes et il ya les
rites 1 c'est chez les goncourt
d'abord on imagine que vous êtes heureux
est ce que vous y attendiez non j'étais
sûr d'être recalé parce qu'on avait
prévenu quelques mois auparavant
oui je sais mais voilà sous les yeux on
ne se refait pas donc je me suis dit ça
ça va être difficile
je ne voulais pas y croire et puis bon
ben voilà oui c'est intéressant on est
un peu aux candidats ou alors on a bien
sûr on vous propose des postes on voit
ce dont vous propose le poste mais à
condition vous l'acceptiez c'est à dire
qu'on vous sont plusieurs mois avant
votre éditeur vous sont d'aussi et il y
avait un certain nombre de conditions
notamment d'abandonner le comité de
lecture de grâce et auquel j'appartiens
depuis pas mal d'années
avec les autres éditeurs depuis qu'ils
ont toujours raison pas ce genre de
choses encore pour le concours
non non c'est pas non c'est pas ça
s'appelle c'est à dire d'être dans
l'aide proche de grâce est complet bien
sûr des jurés en fonction oui non
d'affinités des poivrons les mettre à
jour le cam c'est vrai bien sûr et et
c'est normal c'est normal et donc on
vous sondez on vous dit voilà le vote
aura lieu tel jour
et hier comme un fait exprès j'avais
joué et est allé déjeuner j'avais oublié
mon portable
en fait je n'avais pas envie de savoir
quand je suis arrivé il y avait voilà la
bonne nouvelle était là et donc mais
c'est une charge énorme
le genre de lecteurs que vous n'êtes pas
ce qu'on connaît vos écrits je défais je
lisais beaucoup de manuscrits la falloir
je dise les vraies div
donc c'est un peu une continuité qu'est
ce que vous êtes en fait si vous voulez
le le goncourt c'est la participation à
la création littéraire du moment c'est à
dire qu'on est directement dans le dans
le coeur du réacteur pour parler comme
tout à l'heure le député socialiste et
donc c'est l'axé ça ce ça se joue et
puis elle concours de poésie et le
goncourt de la nouvelle le goncourt de
la biographie et ya les goncourt
étrangers je vous dis ça parce que je
viens de l'apprendre donc je suis je
suis tout neuf
donc on voyage c'est en fait très
contraignant et ses bénévoles je tiens à
le dire ça n'est pas ça n'est pas payé
mais bon c'est prestigieux purnell on a
un sentiment de tenir entre ses mains le
sort d'un certain nombre d'auteurs qui
seront seront pas récompensés ou qu'ils
seront longtemps après leurs espérances
mais qu'ils seront un jour en tout cas
félicitations
je voudrais vous interroger sur la ferme
à seneffe qui a conquis a connu des des
rebondissements aujourd'hui qui a
ébranlé on le sait le milieu littéraire
et l'édition française perquisitions qui
ont eu lieu aux éditions gallimard à
paris dans le cadre de l' enquête qui a
été ouverte par par le parquet les
enquêteurs s'intéressent au profil de
christian giudicelli j'imagine que que
vous le connaissez c'est un éditeur qui
d'après les premiers éléments de
l'enquète qui sont publiées sur
mediapart accompagné gagner les matches
9 lors de ses voyages aux philippines
dans les années 80 quelle est votre
réaction ce soir il faut que la justice
passe
on cherche à tout prix des victimes pour
que l'accusation et
une consistance c'est un peu une version
des faits dans le cadre de son
mais c'est pas la peine d'aller
perquisitionner chez gallimard chez
gallimard tout est dans les livres de
base nef pour qui voulait venir le
problème c'est que gabriel matzneff
était tombé dans l'oubli et que
paradoxalement le livre de vanessa swing
orale ressuscité même l'immortaliser
parce que désormais je pense que ces
ouvrages vont se vendre à prix d'or
non pas sur amazon de ce qu'ils
imaginent qu'il va être aussi évacué
d'amazon je trouve pas ça très
prestigieux de cracher sur quelqu'un qui
est à terre personnellement je le la
pédophilie me dégoûte mais un vieux
monsieur de 83 ans que tout le monde
courtisait jusqu'à il ya peu et que tout
d'un coup on vous je me dis mais ce qui
se passe c'est que les peuples se
rattraper sur ses erreurs et ses
aveuglements et donc on se rattrape
rétrospectivement on désigne par exemple
pivot comme complice de mazet pour
bernard pivot ni-ni ni pouvait mais il a
peut-être voilà ricaner devant ma se
défend dans les années 90 vous l'auriez
dit eh ben oui je bosse j'ai dit et
parce que j'ai lu le manuscrit
c'est par moi j'étais à des premières le
manuscrit
j'ai trouvé très bon et il n'est pas
dans la vengeance elle l est et c'est ça
qui est très fort elle l'est beaucoup
moins dans la vengeance que dans ses
interviews
elle est plutôt dans comment ai-je pu me
laisser prendre au baratin de cet homme
qui m'a tellement impressionné en fait
ce qu'elle lui reproche c'est de l'avoir
abandonnée enfin plutôt de l'avoir
trompé avec d'autres filles puisque base
mais vous savez c'est un vaste système
ils couchaient chaque semaine avec
plusieurs jeunes filles et comme il
était pris d'une graphomane il écrivait
tout est donc un jour elle a découvert
le pot-aux-roses elle est partie et elle
dit je crois me souvenir que si massenet
favet continue à l'aimer et elle
n'aurait jamais
eu cette crise terrible qui a été la
sienne et qu'il ya quand même détruit sa
vie donc oui un peu plus compliqué que
ça elles assimilent aussi à un
pédocriminels oui c'est un pédocriminels
bon est-ce que la dernière question là
dessus
la vague mitu qui peut continuer à des
fermes et peut-être davantage encore sur
le monde littéraire ce qu'il faut
l'aider à déferler
il faut l'aider à condition qu'elle
débouche sur des actions en justice
c'est à dire que ce qu'on a reproché à
balances ton port et amis tous et à
juste titre c'est que c'est des
proclamations vengeresses à l'intention
d'un certain nombre d'individus
soupçonnés de viols ou d'agressions mais
c'est pour ça qu'on a on a demandé un
délai neil de déposer plainte parce que
si ici n'importe qui peut se venger de
n'importe qui sur la toile sur les
réseaux pas que c'est ton à la vindicte
et voilà donc ça tourne à l'âme indique
hubert vous n'avez pas de compte twitter
non je n'ai pas de compte twitter je
m'épargne serait justement je ne voulais
pas non je ne veux pas ni facebook non
les là je suis d'une autre génération et
j'essaie d'éviter les affrontements par
eric instagram en fait est un chat non
non rien du tout aucune empreinte
numérique
justement je pose la question parce que
vous allez sûrement être édifié par ce
sujet merci beaucoup
françois on se retrouve la semaine
prochaine des jeunes parfois âgés d'à
peine 10 ans qui se retrouve star du web
il teste toutes sortes de produits des
pubs des indes et avec l'accord de leurs
parents des bonbons toutes sortes de
nourriture ils font face sur des chaînes
des chaînes youtube qu'ils ont créé et
ils cumulent des millions et des
millions de vues sans le moindre cadre
légal on regarde les explications
d'hélène bonduelle et on en parle juste
après et là il est petit
oui des petites paillettes machin que tu
peux mettre dessus d'un coup tu vas
faire comme tu veux être à licorne et
une montre afin qu'elle nous allons
montrer ses savons maintenant va nous
montrer sont pas ta bulle salit pas
et puis motion
joli petit qui sont ces prêts on appelle
ça des vlog en français des blogs
exclusivement vidéos dans lesquelles les
internautes racontent leur vie montrent
leur quotidien ou teste des produits et
depuis plusieurs années le phénomène a
atteint les mineurs studio bungie soit
nenê ou encore des mots jouer les
internautes mise en scène par leurs
parents ont entre 7 et 14 ans et leur
vidéo cartonne sur la plateforme youtube
le jeune swan a même commencé quand il
avait trois ans quand même très bonne
édition 12 3 millions certains youtuber
mineurs ont posté jusqu'à 30 vidéos par
mois des heures entières passées devant
la caméra un vanter les mérites d'une
marque ou d'un parc d'attraction pour
eux c'est forcément sur le temps de
loisirs une fois que toute la partie
scolaire et devoirs est terminée donc
mercredi après midi ou le week-end
gassion un loisir pas si sûr justement
l'observatoire de la parentalité et de
l'éducation numérique a réalisé une
enquête il y a deux ans et selon lui
cette activité est en fête du travail
dissimulé
quand on nous répond qu'il s'agit d'une
activité de loisir accord alors que leur
nombre sont déposés sous forme de marque
des sociétés qui sont montés que
certains parents ont créé les lignes de
jouer ou ont sorti des albums des livres
des agendas scolaires etc
tous les parents qui nous regardent
comprendront bien que on est quand même
très très loin de la simple activité
loisirs d'autant que ces vidéos rapporte
de l'argent près de 150000 euros par
mois pour les plus grosses chaînes
certains parents ou même arrêter de
travailler pour se consacrer à ses
vidéos familiales où nous pensons et
c'est ce que dit la loi qu'il serait
souhaitable que ces enfants youtuber
puisse également avoir un compte en
banque
alors non sans lesquels sont versées les
fonds qui resterait bloquée jusqu'à leur
majorité
en réalité il préconise comme le député
bruno stud heures dont cadrer ce travail
des mineurs à l'image de ce qui existe
dans le mannequinat ou le cinéma par
exemple ce spécialistes s'inquiètent
aussi du droit à l'image des mineurs et
surtout du droit à l'oubli sur internet
d'ici quelques mois quelques années
quand ces enfants vont grandir vont
chercher à se socialiser
je pense que globalement
on risque d'avoir des avocats qui vont
se frotter les mains de se retrouver
face à des situations un petit peu du
est-ce qu avec pourquoi pas des enfants
qui à terme risque serait de vouloir
porter plainte contre leurs parents un
phénomène d'autant plus inquiétants
qu'aujourd'hui un enfant sur cinq a déjà
un profil numérique créées avant même sa
naissance
bonsoir bonne au stud rjc d'être avec
nous vous êtes le président de la
commission des affaires culturelles à
l'assemblée député la république en
marche du bas-rhin et c'est vous qui
vous attaquer au fond à ce vide
juridique qui existe votre proposition
de loi est discutée d'ailleurs en ce
moment dans l'hémicycle elle va être
adopté un car tout le monde est d'accord
bonsoir justine atlan
vous êtes la directrice de l'association
e-enfance on va essayer de comprendre un
peu le problème déjà d'un point de vue
du diagnostic et vous nous direz ce que
vous allez faire comment vous allez
encadrer ces jeunes youtuber ya là
combien de moins de 16 ans est-ce qu'on
a une idée non on a plusieurs dizaines
de cas sans aucun doute on sait que dans
certains cas il ya des parents qui ont
arrêté de travailler pour se consacrer à
l'activité qui se sont créées autour de
l'exploitation commerciale de l'image de
leurs enfants
il s'occupe d'eux
scénarisée de monter de monétiser de
faire la promotion enfin les parents qui
effectivement évidemment autorise le
droit à l'image puisque c'est eux qui
sont derrière sont comme des managers
csii gagne de l'argent voilà il ya des
parents qui gagnent tellement d'argent
qu'ils ont arrêté toute autre activité
professionnelle pour se consacrer à cela
donc en serait tribu ans via les
publicités que le que les enfants font
les scènes soit c'est effectivement une
monétisation avec la plateforme à la
plateforme vous reverse une partie de la
publicité qu'elle même elle vend pour
les personnes qui sont en train de
visionner cette plateforme de vidéos et
puis après il ya le placement de produit
qui peut générer des revenus directs ou
indirects servir des entreprises qui
voyant que certains enfants pour avoir 1
5 10 millions d'abonnés
c'est ce sont des chiffres qui font
pâlir d'envié toutes les chaînes de
télévision et bien on trouvait là une
forme de téléachat téléachat moderne et
donc font du placement de produit
justice et du loisir ou c'est du travail
dissimulé des enfants alors du travail
dissimulé comme annie brewster il y en a
peu en réalité cyr vraiment on peut
caractériser un lien voilà deux de la
hiérarchie de contraintes de travail
souvent pour les enfants si on est
honnête eux ils vivent comme un loisir
globalement l'enfant maltraité utiliser
l'innovation des enfants parce que le
parent lui comme jodie foster c'est
vraiment une source de revenus donc ça
devient finalement comme un travail pour
le parent mais il va utiliser son enfant
comme outil de travail c'est un peu ça
le problème pour effectivement en
échange être être rémunérés dont il donc
c'est plus d'argent qui intéresse les
parents plutôt que le buzz de leurs
enfants alors il ya forcément un mélange
de tout il ya effectivement des parents
qui vont voilà ce renard ces 6es avec sa
avons trouvé le moyen de voir arriver à
fait popularité qu'ils ont pas eu que
sept enfants et peuvent résoudre le
problème mais au final effectivement il
y en a qui gagnent beaucoup d'argent
puisqu'ils finissent par en vivres et
les plateformes c'est elle qui
l'équilibré mais est-ce qu'on a un moyen
de 2 d'enquêté au fond est ce qu'on sait
si ces enfants passent énormément de
temps sur cette chaîne où ces mercredis
après-midi quand on a fini les devoirs
parce que c'est pas pareil parce qu'ils
se prononcer il ya des parents qui
disent que c'est très peu de temps mais
qu'ils passent leur temps à s'occuper
des enfants certes y en a qui disent
qu'ils font ce que le mercredi après
midi et le samedi
mais eux ils ne s'occupent que leurs
enfants donc le reste du temps on se
demande ce qu'ils font et quel temps
passe vraiment leurs enfants
manifestement à chercher des sponsors de
l'argent voilà voilà en fait cette de
situation il ya une solution vous avez
une relation de travail est clairement
établie sable notamment par le biais de
consignes qui sont données par le parent
et l'enfant et on voit parfois c'est
scénarisé il ya des enfants qui parle
exactement étaient même au même moment
on voit très bien que les consignes donc
là on est dans une relation de travail
même si certains parents ont du mal à
considérer que leurs enfants travaillent
mais quand un enfant je vous dois un
rôle dans au cinéma ou sur dans une
comédie musicale
il s'amuse aussi prend du plaisir aussi
mais pour autant ils travaillent et 13
enfants est interdite sauf dérogation et
ses sables c'est bien ça qu'il faut
rappeler avec cette proposition de loi
internet est un espace de non droit et
après ya des situations effectivement
qu'ils sont qui ont été générés par par
internet parce qu'internet rebattre
toutes les cartes du droit et notamment
la différence entre espace public espace
privé et on voit que le droit du travail
est complètement rebattu également
pascal situation s'est pas vraiment du
travail il ya pas de consignes qui sont
données et pour autant ce n'est plus du
loisir sur les associations qui vouvoie
alerté là dessus comment on en arrive à
un sujet comme ça mais les associations
et entendu un jour un rôle important
parce que elles mêmes ont parfois voulu
ester en justice s'ils n'ont pas pu
aller au bout du de la justice n'a pas
pu aller au bout parce qu'il y avait un
vide juridique que je
un comble est à la fois dans la
situation une relation de travail
clairement établie sable et dans cette
zone grise sur laquelle j'essaie d'agir
maintenant après les associations fait
ce travail là ça a été aussi des
reportages dans les journaux et les
journalistes ont fait des enquêtes
vraiment poussé sur un certain nombre de
ses sujets et donc c'est tout ça qui
amène un agitateur qui à l'écouté de ce
qui se passe on va vraiment se dire ce
que vous allez faire pour encadrer un
petit peu ces jeunes youtuber ou leurs
activités une question sur youtube
youtube qui appartient à google
il n'y a pas de prix nous prend tous
toutes les chaînes youtube même un tout
petit et ça se passe comme ça y'a pas il
n'y a pas de filtre qui a pas
d'autorisation
c'est balance faut dire que la chaîne
n'a jamais du côté des plateformes à bas
les plateformes mais enfin ce qu'elle
vous dis c'est qu'en fait c'est du
déclaratif c'est à dire qu'en fait c'est
un adulte par définition qui va créer
une chaîne c'est c'est vraiment un
enfant en tout cas sur le papier est en
fait c'est vous quand vous créez une
chaîne qui avait coché une case en
disant qu'effectivement dans votre
chaîne va y avoir un mineur s'était donc
c'est du déclaratif comme beaucoup de
fois sur internet c'est votre agent
général on vous demande vous dit vous
avez 18 ans passés du déclaratif
effectivement on vous demande pas de
prouver ce que vous dites et puis on
aidera sur internet donc après c'est ce
qu'on appelle la modération a posteriori
ce tiers qu alors s'il ya des
utilisateurs qui découvre que votre
chaîne voilà qui est par exemple est
déclaré comme étant majeur mais qu'en
fait il ya un enfant de d'en bas c'est
l'internaute quand il est face au
contenu utilisateur qui va avoir la
effectivement la possibilité de signaler
de dire ah bah non cette vidéo là il ya
un enfant alors que c'est pas dit où il
ya beaucoup trop souvent un enfant c est
donc ça le problème c'est que la
responsabilité après elle repose sur
nous tous mais la plateforme considère
que c'est pas sa responsabilité at-elle
de surveiller ça de flics et comme ils
vont dire et voilà que ça nous de le
faire tous parce qu'elle reconnaît être
connus faire le buzz avoir des millions
de vues
ça devient au fond le critère delà de la
réussite pour une partie de la jeunesse
est ce que ça ça vous fait peur ça oui
mais ça me rappelle cette histoire me
rappelle un peu le cas aujourd'hui dans
les années 90 qui chantait dur dur
d'être un bébé et puis kaka vendu 10
millions d'exemplaires qui a été très
connu et qu'ensuite a fait une grosse
dépression je crois
fait un procès à ses parents pour le
coup et donc voilà c'est toujours pareil
une famille entière ce promeut à travers
le petit dernier ou la petite dernière
donc il y avait il ya une renard
civilisation des parents on en devient
tout d'un coup c'est une célébrité
instantanée et puis ensuite il ya un
effondrement et donc il faut espérer que
les enfants survivront à ses shows de
bonbons alors vous avez une minute pour
nous donner les solutions que vous allez
mettre en place d'abord et je veux juste
rebondir là dessus elle a des
dispositions que je vais vous donner
tout de suite mais elle rappelle aussi
que à la tentation de la viralité
il faut privilégier l'impératif de
l'intimité l'enfant a besoin d'intimité
et ça il faut se retirer cette
proposition ne part pas partie donc la
même réglementation que pour les jeunes
enfants mannequins là enfin acteurs
enfants mannequins enfants
qui du spectacle ils ont un régime
protecteur on l'étend et après on crée
un nouveau une nouvelle disposition qui
sont très protectrices dans le cas où il
n'y a pas une relation de travail clair
comme c'est le cas pour les enfants du
spectacle qui voit là sont dans une
récente travail donc dans un désertique
on dit que il ya une déclaration qui est
obligatoire et que les entreprises qui
remettrait des sommes d'argent pour des
placements de produits sans avoir fait
attention à ce que cette déclaration n'a
été faite effectivement soient
punissables
et puis l'oublier le droit à l'oubli en
termine avec sa maman tu as le droit à
l'oubli ce à un moment donné c'est même
sûr donner la possibilité d'effacer
monde et animations voilà d'une vidéo
n'a pas envie de se voir même sans
attendre d'avoir 18 ans merci à tous
d'être de vous restez avec nous parce
qu'on va pas se quitter sans galérer
brochard valérie bouchard qui nous
raconte quoi qui nous raconte sa journée
à l'assemblée où ce soir valérie
exceptionnellement myriam ma journée à
l'assemblée s'est plutôt déroulée hier
soir à l'elysée je vais vous raconter ça
tout de suite
[Musique]
hier soir alors que les députés myriam
était installé hier soir en commission
ici à l'assemblée pour l'examen du texte
sur les retraites
sébastien jumel un élu communiste s'est
inquiété du planning de ses camarades
lrm regarder pour un agenda je voudrais
savoir à quelle heure on doit vous
libérer pour la séance de calinothérapie
parce que semblait pas avoir bonne mine
jeu
la grand-mère et vous fait peine à voir
donc je voudrais savoir à quelle heure
on vous libère voilà ça vous fait
sourire mais vous avez bien entendu une
séance de calinothérapie myriam était
organisée à l'elysée par le maître
shiatsu emmanuel macron lé député
pendant que quitter l'assemblée en bus
regardez un très joli but gris qu'on
devrait voir voilà un très joli but gris
rempli de député de la république en
marche direction le palais du président
de la république blessée par les propos
de leur chef concernant l'allongement du
congé pour parents endeuillés on va pas
refaire l'histoire ce soir vous avez
fait myriam moult débats sur ce sujet
mais par le procès en inhumanité les
élus de la majorité ont été conviés pour
une explication à huit clos avec le
président alors à huis clos
exception faite de ces images regardez
voilà vous savez un c'est un petit peu
comme eh oui on vous demande
un téléphone portable mais parfois on
brave cet interdit pour garder un petit
souvenir
eh bien là c'est eric bothorel qui filme
discrètement la scène on voit emmanuel
macron debout au centre de la pièce
façon un peu grand débat une
intervention en deux parties avec
d'abord un discours puis un jeu de
questions réponses avec les 300 élus sur
place alors aucun journaliste était
présent à l'intérieur de la salle mais
notre reporter stéphanie des pierres en
contact avec certains députés à
l'intérieur de la pièce a pu capturer
quelques passages du discours du
président qu'elle a évidemment rapporté
regarder voilà emmanuel macron a
expressément demandé de continuer à
faire vivre le dépassement et non pas
recréer des chapelles ou aile gauche et
aile droite se répondent en stéréo et
puis concernant le texte congé pour
deuil d'enfant il a précisé sur
l'humanité je n'ai donner de leçon à
personne je me suis exprimé pour qu'il y
ait un pare feu quand on perd une
bataille il faut le reconnaître quand il
ya un tsunami
il faut l'assumer alors voilà pour les
coulisses du discours mais je vous le
disais s'en est suivi un échange avec
les députés qui pour certains n'ont pas
hésité à parler très franchement au
président de leur mission au quotidien
de la distance qu'ils ressentent
vis-à-vis des hautes sphères du pouvoir
c'est une consoeur du figaro qui nous
rapporte ses propos
la députée perrine goulet cible les
cabinets ministériels
ils ne nous croient pas quand on remonte
des trucs du terrain une intervention
apparemment applaudi par ses collègues
alors aujourd'hui myriam évidemment j'ai
tenté d'appeler perrine boulet et les
autres députés qui ont interpellé le
président pour tenter d'avoir un retour
une impression sur cette soirée et son
efficacité mais personne n'a voulu me
répondre parce que le chapitre est clos
à la république en marche
on tourne la page c'est sûr ça s'est
bien passé très bien aller merci à tous
merci
valérie c'est le titre de votre livre
merci à quelques semaines à peine alors
il faut quand même quelques mois à l'est
c'est vrai un peu plus longtemps une
brève éternité philosophie de la
longévité c'est chez grasset
félicitations pour cette nomination va
suivre vont nuire si vos choix vos
délibérations
merci à vous bonsoir très belle soirée
et demain
[Musique]